91 of people who filled out a bracket in
the chess.com Global Championship picked
the five-time world chess champion the
schwanathan Anand to win against the
resilient Pavel pencarov things began
well in game one as Vichy opened up a
big advantage against pinkradov's French
defense Vichy trapped pankrado's night
and looked to be converting smoothly
after a nice Advance Knight to H7 so he
he was fully intending on the night to
die and just making some sort of
blockade in the position which okay
that's fine wow
what what vicious like nah I'm gonna win
your night and we're not going to trade
Rooks like I'm not I mean night age this
is what I mean the French is an opening
where especially these Mainline winowers
like I don't think this was quite a
Cutting Edge Main Line it was a little
bit of a sideline but I this is the
reason we don't see this opening in
classical tournaments at Super GM level
anymore I I was listening to you Levy
and I was taking over the end but I'm
still just so mesmerized by the move
Knight H7 it's so disrespectful I mean
he could have just taken his Knight and
vishi's like has a sense of humor
he's just like no I'm not taking it but
you know it does make a lot of sense
because this Rook on H1 it is defending
the white king it also is covering that
B1 Square in case of a queen B6 so the
995 immobilized because then on E7 is
loose so I actually love the decision I
never would have found that myself on
being completely transparent uh but if
we had traded Rooks on h8 instead you
can already see the evaluation is going
in Black's favor it says equal but with
Rook H2 check problems with this white
king over here I can completely
understand the move as it's Justified I
just wouldn't have seen it in advance in
the time scramble the position became
messy and pencarov escorted his Pawn all
the way to A2 it even looked as though
Vichy could be in trouble but with
precise play he secured a repetition
you know still actively engaging his
opponent in various aggressions despite
looking like his King is just on the
verge of
total decimation I think you will repeat
moves I I don't think he cannot repeat
moves but can he I mean is there
anything else I don't think so in game
two punkrat have achieved early pressure
against vichy's open rui Lopez and never
let up the nice tactic Bishop takes D5
earned the brilliant annotation from
game review according to the engine only
Rook C2 would have resisted Vichy did
seek counter play against pankada's King
but precise play from Pavel held
everything together
oh gosh and then it's just a positional
night work nightmare everywhere
yeah and pankaratov is just gonna apply
the squeeze here yep Queen F4 nice just
slow Improvement not allowing Vichy any
counter play on The Queen side
you gotta love moves like King H2 right
just like a calm little move bringing
the king forward off the background oh
yeah oh God
oh
gosh it's not good it's not good Queen
G4 wow oh my goodness pankrative is just
ah just lights out this game yeah vishy
sacrificing a rook to try to get some
sort of
Perpetual or
but I I don't think there's anything
I mean his his influences is amazing and
he I think he's looking for the
resign button yeah he never uses that
button so he doesn't know where it is
but yeah
he runs out of time because he doesn't
know where the resign button is because
he never has to use it good Lord what a
flex
with a point advantage in game three and
on the verge of an upset pancrat have
played solidly with black and looked to
be well positioned to draw for much of
the game until in the end game Vichy had
two incredible opportunities to advance
his King unintuitively to the third Rank
and secure surprising wins
yeah this is a big win for Vichy he gets
it done while he doesn't quite get he's
on the path to getting it done right now
good thing he has four bars of
connection we don't see it on the
current screen but that's all right oh
what what is happening what oh my
goodness apparently he made a mistake
we'll go back right here the king C1 is
the obvious move but apparently King A2
that's the way to go and if Rook takes
C2 then the king just comes to B4 and
then you win this pawn and your Pawn
runs oh no
oh no
and
so pankrant of doing his best here and
the King now
is very close to this bee pawn and this
Rook can come in D2
oh no that was right oh my god that
actually probably is part of it it's
part of the reason why Vichy made a
mistake in this ending is he didn't have
that much time probably got a little bit
nervous oh
and a blunder right back yay blunders
but what it what is it is it B6 or H6
he's got 30 seconds time is ticking
which one is it
I wonder if he well actually I played B6
because the problem is we play H6 there
might be king C5 so in B6 I can keep
going to B7 so the pawn this Pawn gets
Advanced first and then the second Pawn
can run H6 King C5 is so brutal so B6
rugby two but isn't there like rugby one
and then C2 somehow but rugby two
doesn't threaten Rook takes B6 because
the Rook G6 checks maybe there's King D1
Ah that's probably what he missed are I
don't know but he obviously missed
something because when you take the pawn
you're basically allowing your opponent
to push and you would have probably
expected B7 but the fact that Rook B2 is
not a threat is so sneaky and that's
such a critical difference if we can
bring up analysis board really quickly
here we can show exactly the difference
because if the H Pawn had run instead uh
here then this Rook comes to H2
threading this Pawn push and you could
take this Pawn there's no skewer there's
no check on the sixth rank after so as
we get to the live position here it look
wait what he missed it no how what
oh no fishy
time trouble
wait what is going on
it's just a draw that's it and Vichy is
really upset you just saw on his face he
looked to the side he's just like what
happened there let's go back to that in
a must-win situation with the black
pieces Vichy turned to the sharp
Sicilian Defense pankradov selected the
moroxy bind a solid option suiting his
need for just a half point but then he
played the inventive overly inventive
consecutive moves G4 and King D1
castling Queen Side by hand shocking the
commentators the engine did not approve
and Vichy found the flaws and secured a
big advantage
right
are you seeing that move
what
is that a mouse slip no he seems what
what Robert do you and I not understand
chess
let's go back two moves here I mean
black is much better we see the eval but
we don't even need the eval what is he
doing what
have you ever seen this before
you mean you don't usually play G4 and
then follow up with King D1 that's not
what you're I mean I I understood like
King D1 must have been to go King C2
King B1 and castle by hand but Robert
respectfully what the what
it what is this I
black is spoiled for Choice here you can
play B5 there's a king on C2 let's open
up this position and you want to play D5
okay so vicious vicious moves are
obvious
I can't comprehend this I think I think
he's doing it for the fans Punk Crossing
wants the fans to enjoy an Armageddon
game
Robert he just he just sat there and
shook his head what's he shaking his
head at he's the one who played the
moves like he did it to himself Vision
just developed this piece it's not like
fishy started a crazy attack
just out of nowhere went G4 King D1 King
C2 King B1 what
if
I don't understand now there's two pawns
under attack
Pavel played a piece act to mix things
up but Vichy was unperturbed and soon
secured the full point there's gonna be
another game for Pablo I'm looking at
him as if he just lost the most
important game of his life and maybe
that's true
but he gets another game after this
yep and that's it
resignation if Queen takes F5 Queen
takes G1 with check then this queen is
picked up so vishwanathan Anand the
five-time world chess champion wins with
black he needed to get this one
and they're going to Armageddon with the
match going to one final Armageddon game
white would have 15 minutes on the clock
black would get draw odds but the
players had to submit a bid with the
amount of time they were willing to play
with to get black and the coveted draw
odds the previous day almost all bids
were around 11 or 12 minutes a hefty
handicap for black but a manageable one
pankwarov clearly showed that he wanted
only one thing the white pieces and a
victory he bid 14 and a half minutes
Vichy shocked the event coordinators the
commentators and the world with a bid of
just seven minutes less than half of
pankrado's bid chess.com staff were
stunned but Vichy confirmed his bid
indicating his confidence and his speed
and defensive skills with the black
pieces but we have a bidding system
Robert and would you like to fill in the
viewers on uh what we just got told
during the break yeah I'm still typing
to the team behind the scenes because
Vichy on and bid seven minutes so he
will have the black pieces with seven
minutes Pablo Punk crosov will have 15
minutes with white and Pavel needs to
win so I was confirming a few things
that vishi knew that there was no
increment that he knew that the base
time was 15 minutes the team actually
asked him those specific questions seven
mids black was 15 White this she said
correct repeated it uh you know vocally
as well so I'm shocked but this she must
have that much confidence in his ability
to draw with black and his bullet skills
yeah that's completely nuts that she
played to neutralize pankrada's opening
Advantage securing good squares in the
center for his minor pieces
unfortunately his efforts to get pieces
off of the board and to simplify even at
the cost of a pawn were rejected by
pancratav who kept things complicated
and kept up pressure on the clock I
wonder if punk rock is in that mindset
he looks fully concentrated Levy but I
get the sense that he kind of is
trusting Vichy and that can also add to
your nerves absolutely and also
realizing that you actually don't have
forward progress it's a very frustrating
feeling and to mention not to mention
that your your time Gap has gone from
eight to three minutes so I did mention
a while ago that they're gonna get to
around two minutes at the same time
because of the pace of the game wow that
is a giant decision my vision I am
shocked but Bishop C4 you think
where else is that Bishop going I guess
there's like a queen C5 check at some
point but as Bishop comes out to E3 this
is becoming a potential nightmare for
Vichy if this Pawn can get up to F5
oh boy
this should be three does he have D4 the
ship F2 and queen F2
yeah oh oh wow wow
just as Vishing narrowed pankrado's time
advantage to its minimum pancotta found
consecutive shots with G6 and then F6
soon forcing Checkmate before she's just
he's playing on instant he has to he is
not that afraid but G6 oh my gosh oh
that is a crazy looking move
all the pawns looks horrible to deal
with
what's she gonna do oh no he's gonna
lose his game I mean there's no way to
survive with the King here
and pankrative looking like he is in
Tip-Top shape here to deliver a final
blow in a couple of moves and he will be
the last person in group F to make it to
the round of 32 what a battle
and what a stare punk rock has I mean
that guy's scaring me I'm not even his
opponent
yeah I mean just just a very strange
turn of events these last few games yeah
but she doesn't
I feel like Vichy once again doesn't
exactly know where the resign button is
I think he looks like he's looking
around yeah he's gonna resign and you
can just tell by you know he's trying to
find it he's not used to it he doesn't
resign very often
after pankada's shocking upset of Anand
only five perfect rackets remain of the
more than 10 000 that were submitted
surely more surprises are ahead in the
chess.com Global championship
[Music]